en el último vídeo les dije que este
resultado que obtuvimos del área de un
triángulo cuyos lados son
hice es equivalente a la fórmula de
verón y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es demostrarles que es equivalente
a la fórmula de verona haciendo unas
cuantas manipulaciones algebraicas lo
primero que queremos hacer déjenme
saltarme este un medio sé que está
debajo del símbolo radical un medio se
es lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada de c al
cuadrado sobre 4 tomamos la raíz
cuadrada de esto y obtenemos un medio c
entonces esta expresión completa es
igual a en vez de dibujar el radical voy
a escribir la raíz cuadrada
de esto desea al cuadrado partido por 4
por todo esto
muerto esto voy a copiar y pegar
bueno por todo esto y por supuesto hay
que distribuir por lo tanto sé
al cuadrado partido por 4 por todo esto
y luego tenemos que cerrar la raíz
cuadrada
déjeme distribuir c
al cuadrado partido por 4 esto va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada eso será un
poco enredado pero creo que se sentirán
satisfechos al ver cómo esto se vuelve
algo tan simple como la función de orón
la raíz cuadrada de s al cuadrado
partido por 4 x al cuadrado s al
cuadrado
al cuadrado sobre 4 - al cuadrado sobre
4 esté distribuyendo esto y voy a
ponerlo como el numerador al cuadrado
partido por el denominador al cuadrado
entonces por c al cuadrado más al
cuadrado menos b al cuadrado al cuadrado
partido si elevó al cuadrado el
denominador será 4 c al cuadrado
e inmediatamente vemos que sea al
cuadrado y que sea al cuadrado sé
tacharán déjeme cerrar todos los
paréntesis y por supuesto este 4 por
este 4 va a ser bien déjeme ponerlo de
esta forma es lo mismo que 4 al cuadrado
y en vez de poner 16 ya verán porque lo
estoy poniendo así ahora esto se puede
reescribir esto va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada
estoy cambiando de colores
arbitrariamente de cea sobre 2 al
cuadrado
es lo mismo que esto cierto lo pongo
como todo elevado a 2 si el ego al
cuadrado esto s al cuadrado al cuadrado
partido puertos al cuadrado partido por
4 - voy a poner todo esto como una
expresión al cuadrado entonces se al
cuadrado más al cuadrado menos b al
cuadrado partido por 4
y elevamos a 2 el numerador y el
denominador esto puede que sea un tanto
interesante para ustedes déjenme hacer
el paréntesis de un color diferente
puede que se acuerden de la
factorización de polinomios que si
tuviese algo en forma ekiza m cuadrado
al cuadrado estos factores dentro de x
más x x menos y vamos a usar esto una y
otra vez ahora si llamamos a esto se ha
partido por 2x y a todo esto y luego
tenemos x al cuadrado menos y al
cuadrado entonces podemos factorizar
entonces todo esto va a ser igual a la
raíz cuadrada de
x
más y en este caso es se ha partido por
dos más que sea al cuadrado masa
al cuadrado menos b al cuadrado sobre 4
por x menos por lo tanto esta es nuestra
x se ha partido por 2 - todo esto de acá
o aún mejor déjeme decir más y luego
pongo los negativos
entonces más sea al cuadrado negativo
menos al cuadrado más b al cuadrado
sobre 4
bueno todo lo que hice fue dije que esto
es lo mismo que esto más esto esto más
esto por esto menos esto esto menos tan
solo dije más los negativos de esto por
lo tanto menos sea al cuadrado menos al
cuadrado más b al cuadrado todo lo que
hice fue esto aquí ahora veamos si
podemos simplificar esto si podemos
adherir estas fracciones bien podemos
obtener un denominador común se ha
partido por 2 es lo mismo que 12 ha
partido por 4
o sea a partir de oporto se lo mismo que
12 a solo multiplicando el numerador y
el denominador por 2 y ahora podemos
agregar los numeradores entonces nuestra
expresión completa ahora va a ser igual
a la raíz cuadrada
de la
primera expresión se volverá voy a
ponerlo de esta forma pondré sea al
cuadrado
+ 12 a más al cuadrado menos b al
cuadrado todo esto partido por 2
esta es nuestra primera expresión y
luego nuestra segunda expresión se
volverá bien todo será partido por 4
por lo tanto lo pondré esto ahora todo
partido por 4 b al cuadrado podemos
ponerlo de esta forma b al cuadrado
menos
se al cuadrado
- 12
más a al cuadrado
hay que asegurarse que tengamos menos al
cuadrado aquí más x menos es menos al
cuadrado tenemos a más 12 acá menos por
menos es más 12 a tenemos menos sea al
cuadrado aquí tenemos menos c al
cuadrado aquí entonces estos dos son
equivalentes lo siguiente que debemos
reconocer o espero que podamos reconocer
es que esto de aquí
ser un poco enredado soy un poco
enredado
es lo mismo que se masa al cuadrado
déjeme poner esto esto es igual abrimos
paréntesis a la raíz cuadrada
de esto de aquí que se más a al cuadrado
menos b al cuadrado sobre 4
este es el primer término y luego el
segundo estoy acá lo mismo que ese menos
al cuadrado entonces todo esto será
simplificado a b al cuadrado menos al
cuadrado
todo esto partido por 4
estamos avanzando y tal como les dije es
un problema enredado
pero vamos vemos algunas claras
aplicaciones de factorización de
polinomios y ahora vemos cómo una
ecuación muy compleja se puede
transformar en una simple ahora podemos
usar estos mismos números ya tenemos
este patrón algo elevado al cuadrado
menos algo más elevado al cuadrado algo
elevado al cuadrado menos algo más
elevado al cuadrado entonces podemos
factorizar llegaremos en la misma línea
por lo tanto esto va a ser igual a dar
un poco más pequeño tan solo para no
ocupar tanto espacio es igual a la raíz
cuadrada esto va a factorizar esto más
esto entonces se masa más b
por ser más o menos cierto es
exactamente el mismo patrón que hicimos
acá esto es x al cuadrado esto es de al
cuadrado entonces se más o menos b todo
sobre 4 y luego tenemos este de acá que
va a ser b más c menos a déjenme mover
esto un poco por bmc menos a éste es x
por ve más o menos a este es x más por b
- c menos
hoy lo mismo que bebe menos es más
es lo mismo que ve - menos
manos a ciertos bien y todo es todo
sobre 4 sobre 4
4 ahora podemos reescribir esta
expresión completa no quiere ocupar
mucho espacio podemos reescribir esta
expresión completa como
4 es producto de dos por dos
entonces nuestra área de expresión
completa ha sido simplificada
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de esto de
acá
lo que podemos poner como
v
más sobre 2
ese es el término de acá por este
término por este otro
por este otro déjenme poner la
simplificación aquí sé más o menos ve es
lo mismo que más ve más ce a más de más
menos 2 ve estos dos son equivalentes
cierto entonces tenemos a hace y luego
ve menos 2 b será igual a menos b
cierto de menos dos veces menos ve por
lo tanto el siguiente término va a ser a
b c menos 2 b partido por 2
también de ponerlo así déjeme esto
partido por 2 menos esto partido por 2 y
luego nuestro término de acá exactamente
la misma lógica
es lo mismo que
ve más co2
- 2a sobre 2 cierto si agregamos menos 2
nos da menos y por lo tanto tenemos b
más o menos a son exactamente iguales
bueno todo eso partido por 2 o podemos
partir de 1 menores por 2 y luego el
último término
y ya pueden reconocer que aparece la
fórmula de verón
este término de acá
es exactamente igual que a
más ve más c - 2 c cierto al sacar 12 d
se nos da a menos sé y luego aún tenemos
ahí ve partido por 2
podríamos ponerlo como esto partido por
2 menos esto partido por 2 y por
supuesto estamos sacando la raíz
cuadrada de todo esto ahora si definimos
ese si definimos ese s
es igual a más partido por 2 esta
ecuación se simplifica bastante esto es
s esto de acá es s estoy acá es ese y
estoy acá es ese y esto también se
simplifica bastante
- 2 b partido por 2 es lo mismo que me
ve en los dos partidos por 12 lo mismo
que menos a menos 2 de partido por todos
y lo mismo que menos c por lo tanto toda
esta ecuación para nuestra área es igual
voy a escribir la raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada de s
que se está acá la voy a hacer con los
mismos colores por
s - ve por esto es s menos a por y
estamos en el último s
s y ya comprobamos que la fórmula de
heron es lo mismo que probamos al final
del vídeo anterior
fue bastante claro y lo único que
teníamos que hacer era aplicar un poco
de álgebra para comprobarlo